to present the director's Oscar we've
chosen a lady who is one of the
directors most responsive stars
she can play comedy with a feathery
touch her slapstick bring insight to a
dramatic role and quicken the screen
with her energy she is the chief product
distributed by the firm of style with
beauty and rustle miss Rosalind Russell
Bob thank you now tell me why is it that
you always present the presenters but
they never let you present an acts good
well the show is so long now Roz once
the winner got up for we never have time
for a tug-of-war and now the five very
talented men for the best achievement in
direction of a motion picture
Michelangelo Antonioni for blow-up
Claude Lelouch for a man and a woman
Richard Brooks for the professionals
Fred cinnamons
for a man for all seasons and Mike
Nichols for Who's Afraid of Virginia
Woolf
mr. Miller let's end the suspense and
the winner is
Fred cinnamon
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of all
the people who work man for all seasons
especially Robert Board John box and
Bill Graf I would like to thank you for
this great honor I must also thank the
Columbia executives in especially mark
Frankovich for the courage enthusiasm
and faith they had in this project thank
the sudden acceleration of pulse rates
here is caused by the impending Award
for Best Actor and the presence among us
of the lady who will announce him she
was last year's winner and still this
year's darling Miss Julie Christie
Cheerilee I didn't get a chance to
congratulate you last year winning an
Oscar must be the realization of every
girl's dream
well yes Bob it is wonderful but I still
have one dream unrealized what's that
the man strong intelligent but you're
vital
thank you my dear you've given me
something to live for what our
outstanding work in films the Academy
members have nominated these five
talented gentlemen for Best Performance
by an actor Richard Burton and Who's
Afraid of Virginia Woolf Paul Scofield
in a man for all seasons Michael Caine
in Alfie Allen Lockean in the Russians
are coming the Russians are coming and
Steve McQueen in sand pebbles
congratulations all of you the winner is
Paul Scofield
accepting the award from mr. Paul
Scofield in the Best Actor category
wendy hiller
it is a great joy to me to accept this
award on behalf of one of the finest and
one of the most loved actors in my
country there was something very special
in being recognized in the country other
than one's own and I know that Paul
Scofield would want me to say with great
warmth and great humility thank you
imagine not coming here to pick up an
Oscar I flew to Greensboro North
Carolina to become chitlin of the month
the time has come to write the final
headline in the big news story from
Santa Monica the best picture award
we've seen film clips from the five
nominated productions during the past
couple of hours and here is a delicate
Beauty who had the stamina to wait until
now to bring us the chosen one a former
Oscar winner of such beauty charm and
grace we can only call it one thing and
that's an Audrey Hepburn
well do you dear Bob I love you thank
you know and I envy you what do you mean
you end in what a wonderful way you do
this year after year with such skill and
such chain and so effortlessly well
confidentially Audrey after every why
honey don't you get nervous no no
actually I don't but after every show I
go into my dressing room and faint retro
actively we all we have already seen
excerpts from the five nominations for
Best Picture in alphabetical order they
are Alfie a Sheldrake films limited
production paramount louis gilbert
producer a man for all seasons a
highland films limited production
columbia fred winnaman producer the
Russians are coming the Russians are
coming the marriage Corporation of
Delaware production United Artists
Norman Jewison producer the sand pebbles
an argyle solar production 20th Century
Fox Robert Wise producer Who's Afraid of
Virginia Woolf a Chennault production
Warner Brothers Ernest Lehman producer
for best picture of the year may I have
a look
the winner is a man
before we put out the cat others drawing
in an expression of appreciation to the
Academy Awards orchestra John Green at
the mighty baton ladies and gentlemen
take a bow
all about wraps up another
Pricewaterhouse beach party it's all
over what was known only to Oscar now
the whole world knows forth into the
night go to Victor's and the vanquished
the winners will go to the victory
celebration to Beverly Hilton the rest
of you will follow me up the off-ramp
onto the freeway
we know you've enjoyed this two-hour
commercial on behalf of motion pictures
and that you will visit your
neighborhood theater tomorrow to see
that people in pictures Harold in here
tonight and remember there's no law
against going to see some of the losers
if the medium is the message our medium
has a message for us all man has a great
hunger for laughter a great thirst for
beauty and above all man has a great
need to see himself as others seen and
thus to gain a greater understanding of
the emotions of which he is made that
really is what motion pictures do they
interpret human emotions give them
dimension shape form and voice motion
pictures of the full-length mirror in
front of which the world can stand and
see its unlimited capacity for stupidity
or genius for cruelly or kindness for
bigotry or brotherly love it's a vital
work a noble work and believe me ladies
and gentlemen I'm proud to be a partner
thank
you